And then we have Max pooling. So let me return to the
notes Here.
We will take this sum.
of all of these so
okay.
That's all a kind of Illusion is.
the filter
Is that W vector?
So where X is the data and the
data can be anything pictures?
Sequence of words prices like in
the real estate example and W is the filter now
what is a filter? Let me show you picture because that's the best
fastest way to make sense of a filter now in order
for the model to perceive.
The number four it must be able to see.
the vertical lines
the horizontal lines and
diagonal lines if any
If you see here we have how many vertical lines we have
two vertical lines?
this part of the number four
And obviously this part of the number four.
And then the one horizontal line.
Is here?
So we will have one filter.
For the vertical lines that is how we will arrange now. They
don't have they haven't shown you the combination. Like how
what numbers would you put in the filter? But
I'll show it to you in a minute.
Anyway, so this will be a matrix the filter Matrix.
And one you convolve this Matrix with
the original Matrix, you can
see we'll get the we will get these signals.
So you can see here. We have the number three.
Three's a very strong signal
and two
is a strong but not as strong. But anyway, we
the model has perceived is
able to see those two lines.
So they this part corresponds to
that and by the way, why is this
three? Well, because when we took a stride here, we saw
three when you take a stride here.
the signal weakens
And when you come down here the signal weakens even some more.
Right because it's affected by these zeros.
and then
yeah.
These are all three but because we have a completely white
pixels.
all the way from top to bottom
same thing here for the horizontal lines.
There are there is not a horizontal line so
to speak because but there is some.
Activity, but it's not strong enough to constitute a line, which
is why the signal is weak up here.
Here, however, we have would you have a strong signal?
But you have these tools because they're
affected by these zeros.
And then we have no vertical lines. Excuse me. We have no higher
than the lines in this part of the Matrix, which is why
The signal is completely weak.
But if you try to visualize this if you want to put these
two matrices together.
If you were to put these Matrix if I would like to take this three.
And bring it up here.
It would form the number four.
And there's nothing across the diagonal. So this is weak altogether.
kernels also synonymous with filter
Okay.
So for example if you put a five.
In sorry about that if you put a 5 in here.
in the middle
then and negative ones.
In these places, then you're going to sharpen the image.
So when you convolve
this picture with that.
Matrix
the effect will be to sharpen the image you can see we get
a clear outline of the person's face
where the eyes are where the lips are. So this
is going to be easier to classify than the picture on the left.
Okay.
I can look it up and show you what numbers are arranged
in the filters. So for emboss.
You can see will be two one zero.
You get the idea, right? That's the point.
And then we have Max pooling.
Matrix
of weights to
put in quotation marks perceive
the
what's the what's a good word to use here?
to perceive the
outlines for example of the
picture
vertical line vertical
lines horizontal lines